if the headline of sequoias slide deck
was r.i.p good times during the
financial crisis what would the headline
be today gravity hasn't been repealed
what do you mean by that if they're not
properly constructed so how do you see
this playing out I mean you told the
London Times that a whole bunch of crazy
little companies will disappear a
considerable number of unicorns will
become extinct does this bubble burst or
is there a soft landing to me it's much
more it's a more rational time than 1999
because I don't think there's a sort of
universal feeling that every company is
going to be a massive success and people
are a bit more discriminating and but
there are you could just look at
yesterday's incredible story in The Wall
Street Journal about theron offs to
understand that way and I don't pretend
to know a lot about the details of that
company but if true and if similar
things are true about other companies
that have very high and sporty
valuations some of them are going to
come a cropper but in these same
collection of unicorns are companies
that are going to become the great
enduring technology companies of the
next 10 and 20 years what does that mean
they will and you know the fair know
story is a perfect example it you know
how many of these are out there do you
worry that there are a few quite a few
well I don't worry about you know it's
it's the lure of corporate business
evolution if people get too big for
their britches
if the companies are run poorly if money
is wasted if the product or service
doesn't really fulfill its promise the
companies deserve to fail how protected
are late-stage investments in this
environment many late stage investments
aren't really investments they're just
disguised forms of debt and they're very
well protected
many of them are very well protected
because of the terms that investors have
put around them the ratchets the
ratchets the liquidation preferences
these aren't really equity investments
their debt but is that a dangerous trend
these ratchets and the guaranty that
investors will get a certain amount back
if the if the company doesn't perform
yes it's high-risk poker